hello everyone I've already shown you
magnus carlsen went over Fabiano Caruana
in the 8th round of the isle of man
international tournament so it would
only be fair to show you this brilliant
game played by Hikaru Nakamura against
the Israeli Grandmaster and also toski
the game is well it's I really enjoyed
it I hope you will enjoy it as well so
look more eyes white and he plays d4 we
have d5 c4 and the d captures on c4
Queens gambit accepted Nakamura goes for
e4 Knight to f6 attacking d4 pawn and E
5 is played Knight to d5 and the bishop
captures on c4 grabbing the pawn back
Bishop to a5 we have rights to e2 and
our East 6 and nakamura castles night to
b6 attacking the bishop on c4 we have a
Bishop to b3 and now c5 ok we have
Bishop to e3 nakamura develops a piece
and well here so toasty plays c4 and
well his King is still in the center of
the board he needs to he requires two
more moves to castle so nakamura goes
for the challenge he plays the Bishop
captures in c4 and this wasn't a bad
idea by mo so toski but he missed one
move that Nakamura found we have Knight
captures on c4 and now Queen today for
check well attacking the knight on c4
Knight to d7 defending and now Queen
captures on c4 we're up to c8 with an
attack on the Queen Queen back to a4 now
again pinning the night and this is
pseudo skis idea place
Bishop to c2 now attacking the Queen
although Bishop to e7 might have been a
better move as well even given up this a
seven pawn he should definitely Castle
here but he played Bishop to c2 now with
an attack on the Queen and nakamura
again accepts the challenge he grabs the
pawn Queen captures an a7 and well this
is the idea
she plays Bishop to d3 no attacking this
night the knight is pinned of course if
he moves Bishop captures rook on f1 and
the camera goes night b2 c3 and now
Bishop to e6 and now Nakamura's queen is
trapped as the knight is covering
v6 and also c5 but this is the idea
Nakamura had he plays d5 and okay mo
captures the pawn on e5 Knight captures
on e5 and now rook at the d1 now well
with an x-ray attack on the screen and
e8 night to d3 is played to block the
rook and now Nakamura plays D captures
an e6 and this is very unpleasant for
black black can't capture this pawn
would have captures on e6 if F captures
any six you get Knight to f4 now this
net is attacking this pawn on e6 this
night on d3 is attacked twice and well
black still has the castle for example
Bishop to e7 and our Knight captures on
d3 Bishop captures and III and Queen to
a4 check and you can't block the check
with the Queen if you block the check
with the Queen simply Queen captures
Queen and then you lose this bishop on
d3 probably a move that could be played
as something like King to f7 but this is
again very unpleasant for black and well
a very interesting the line is rook to
c6 now the King can still castle but now
when Nakamura has worked to d2 preparing
to double up on this Bishop so after
black castle simply queen to be one now
what an attack on this Bishop here and
well you have to defend it rook to d6
and our Bishop to c5 and well you can't
really move the rook because what will
capture the bishop on e7 and then win
the piece here but if something like
Bishop to c2 then wrote captures and e6
Bishop captures on d6 and Queen captures
and e6 again winning a piece so after D
D captures and e6 by nakamura tsutomu
played Bishop to d6 given up one pawn
well for for some play Nakamoto plays it
captures an f7 with check King captures
on f7 and we have a queen to d4 now
well the queen is very nicely placed
here also this Knight is attacked twice
and well amyl still has the castle so
rook to e8 preparing to castle
artificially and nakamura goes Queen to
d5 check
of course not allowing the king to go to
g8 and well no notice that the Nakamura
can't win the night here by rock capture
I mean two pieces for the rook with rock
at verse and III because after Bishop
capture somebody through Queen captures
you have this very unpleasant Bishop
captures nh-2 check after King captures
you lose the Queen on d3 so after rook
to e8 of course Nakamura found another
way to grab the piece he plays Queen to
d5 would check King to f8 is played and
now Queen to f5 check and now well if
you block if you lock this with the
Queen that's really not very good you'll
lose the pond in h7 and then the black
king is completely bare
so King to g8 is played and now we have
a Bishop to g5 kicking the Queen away
from the D file Queen to c7 is played
and we have Queen to d5 now with two
check
and now this knife can be captured so
King to h8 is played and our Nakamura
plays rook captures on d3 Bishop
captures on h2 well grabbing that pawn
but it doesn't do black much good King
to h1 is played and our Bishop to c4 now
attacking this Queen Queen to d7 is
played the Queen cannot be captured as
well white is up a piece a six is played
and here nakamura plays a very calm move
he plays g3 and now this Bishop on h2 is
trapped so Tosca plays H capture some g5
and we have Queen captures on c7 rook
captures on c7 and now rook to d2 not
allowing this bishop to capture and also
now this Knight is defended twice with
the rook and with the knight the bishop
on h2 is still trapped rook to f7 and
final try I'm going for that f2 pawn but
Nakamura just plays Knight d4 and in
this position
a most Adamski resigned the game this is
moved 31 so a very nice showing by
Hikaru Nakamura the rook is now
protecting this f2 pawn the bishop is
still trapped so no point in continuing
this torture white is completely winning
here so yeah that's the game after eight
rounds Hikaru Nakamura has clear second
place with six and a half points
tomorrow he will face
world champion magnus carlsen and they
will decide the faith of the tournament
and who will be the king of the island
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon